well yesterday was an historic day uh
there was last minute testimony
scheduled in the january 6 committee
from a former aide
to trump chief of staff mark meadows her
name is cassidy hutchinson this was
scheduled relatively last minute it was
expected to be explosive and it was in
fact it was so
potentially explosive that i even
cancelled yesterday's bonus show oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad and if i cancel that
you know something's big is going on and
indeed it was yesterday we received
testimony from cassidy hutchinson former
aide to former trump chief of staff mark
meadows that donald trump knew there
were people at his january 6 rally with
guns and he wanted the metal detectors
turned off so more people could get in
saying they don't want to hurt me
trump was so determined to go to the
capitol with the rioters that he
allegedly assaulted a secret service
officer and attempted to commandeer his
vehicle he also threw his lunch at the
wall leaving a ketchup stain dribbling
down the walls of the white house and so
many other claims let's get right into
it
like nothing we've ever heard before the
impression from mr meadows that the off
the record movement to the capitol was
still possible and likely to happen but
that bobby had more information
so once the president had gotten into
the vehicle with bobby
he thought that they were going up to
the capitol and when bobby had relayed
to him
we're not we don't have the assets to do
it it's not secure
we're going back to the west wing
the president had
very strong a very angry response to
that
tony described him as being irate
the president said something to the
effect of
i'm the effing president
take me up to the capitol now
to which bobby responded sir
we have to go back to the west wing sir
the president
reached up towards the front of the
vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
mr engel grabbed his arm
said sir you need to take your hand off
the steering wheel
we're going back to the west wing we're
not going to the capitol
mr trump then used his free hand to
lunge towards bobby angle and
when mr ornato had recounted the story
to me he had motioned towards his
clavicles wow
and was mr engel
in the room as mr ornato told you this
story he was
did mr engel correct or disagree with
any part of the story from mr ornato mr
engel did not
correct or disagree with any part of the
story
did mr engel or mr ornato ever after
that tell you that what mr ornato had
just said was untrue
neither mr ornato nor mr engel told me
ever that it was untrue
wow
wow
assaulting the allegations here are
assaulting a secret service agent
attempting to commandeer the vehicle and
i guess i mean i don't know that donald
trump knows how to drive i'm not aware
of him ever driving but i guess
attempting to redirect the vehicle
towards where he wanted to go
and a determination to go to the capitol
now this is arguably the most
sort of salacious allegation but the
undertone of all of it is a degree of
premeditation
and foreknowledge that armed violent
people would be coming to the capitol on
january 6th
and a desire for them to be there and a
desire for them to wreak havoc and an
expectation that they would no one was
surprised in the trump circle that this
is the way it went on january 6th
incredible allegations now there are now
reports
that some of the secret service officers
mentioned
dispute and are willing to well get them
under oath okay what we have right now
is cassidy hutchinson under oath and we
have trump posting on truth social or
truth central
and claims to reporters that secret
service say well put them under oath
right now this is what we have under
oath okay
second series of allegations that are
absolutely outrageous but not
particularly shocking
that trump threw a fit so large that he
launched his food at the wall of course
his lunch include ketchup unclear
whether they were
dinosaur-shaped chicken nuggets or what
he was eating with the ketchup that's
not a detail we have
but uh trump losing it and leaving
ketchup dripping down the wall
the physical altercation that miss
hutchinson described in the presidential
vehicle
was not the first time that the
president
had become very oh sorry and that's so
first we're looking at a we're looking
at one other clip here but we're going
to get to the ketchup angry about issues
relating to the election
on december 1 2020 attorney general barr
said in an interview that the department
of justice had not not found evidence of
widespread election fraud sufficient to
change the outcome of the election
ms hutchinson
how did the president react to hearing
that news
around the time that i understand
the ap article went live
i remember hearing noise coming from
down the hallway so i poked my head out
of the office i saw the valet walking
towards our office he had said
get the chief down to the dining room
the president wants him
so mark went down to the dining room
came back to the office a few minutes
later
after mark had returned i left the
office and went down to the dining room
and i noticed that the door was propped
open and the valley was inside the
dining room changing the tablecloth off
of the dining room table
he motioned for me to come in
and then pointed towards the front of
the room near the fireplace mantle and
the tv where
i first noticed there was ketchup
dripping down the wall and there's a
shattered porcelain plate on the floor
the valet had articulated that the
president
was
extremely angry
at the attorney general's ap interview
and had thrown his lunch against the
wall
um
which was causing them to have to clean
up so i grabbed a towel and started
wiping the catch up off the wall to help
the valet out
and he said something to the effect of
he's really ticked off about this
i would stay clear of him for right now
he's really really ticked off about this
right now
wow
ketchup
ketchup down the wall and apparently
trump would regularly throw dishes and
um
that was also testified too i started
wiping the catch up off the wall to help
the valet out um
and he said something to the effect of
he's really ticked off about this
i would stay clear of him
for right now he's really really ticked
off about this right now
and miss hutchinson was this the only
instance that you are aware of where the
president
threw dishes
it's not
and are there other instances in the
dining room that you recall where he
expressed his anger
there were there were several times
throughout my tenure with the chief of
staff that i was aware
of him either throwing dishes or
flipping the tablecloth
um
to let all the contents of the table go
onto the floor there you go just
grabbing the tablecloth and pushing it
up and knocking everything over
this was an unhinged man and most
importantly all i mean listen
throwing ketchup at the wall from your
tendees that your chicken tendees that
you're eating this is not a crime it
does go to trump's instability on and on
and on
but so far there has been no dispute
whatsoever that donald trump
knew and wanted armed people to be let
beyond
the
magnetometers metal detectors with their
firearms
there is no dispute from witnesses that
donald trump was absolutely determined
to get to the capitol with the mob
and there is absolutely no dispute about
all of the claims that everybody mark
meadows trump pat chipoloni you know
whoever
they all knew exactly that what happened
on january 6 was what was expected to
happen no dispute there now one other
thing there are some people making
cassidy hutchinson out to be some kind
of hero cassidy hutchinson is not a hero
okay cassidy hutchinson is cooperating
with an investigation
she if she does not cooperate she is not
like roger stone or whoever okay this is
a
mid-level staffer
the legal hell that could be rained upon
her if she doesn't cooperate or if she
lies under oath is extraordinary she was
part of the maga crowd she worked for
mark meadows and trump she agreed with
all of it she at the very end
she didn't like the way that they were
trying to steal the election but she is
not a hero she's acting out of
self-preservation she was there for a
year or more this is the testimony that
we needed 12 14 15 16 months ago great
that she's here to the extent that she's
telling the truth fantastic but cassidy
hutchinson is not a hero she is here
because she's in serious legal jeopardy
if she's not here
period let's now move on to the hang
mike pence uh circumstances
so the other big thing that came from
yesterday's testimony by a former aide
to former
failed president trump's
former chief of staff mark meadows is
that donald trump seemed to be perfectly
comfortable with and agreeing with the
idea of hang mike pence hang mike pence
is a chant that now has notoriously uh
been associated with the january 6th
protests there were right wingers
chanting hang mike pence they built a
gallows
because they were mad that mike pence
wasn't doing what they believed he
should be doing which is quote sending
the election back to the states
something he couldn't do he had no power
to do it but trump is believed that he
did and they started chanting hang mike
pence hang mike pence
one of the questions that has come up is
why didn't trump do more
to ensure the safety of mike pence why
didn't trump do more to say hey guys
this is our great vice president no no
no none of this hang mike penn stuff and
the reason that we now know trump didn't
do anything about it is because he
agreed with the sentiments hang mike
pence we now have another witness who
says
trump believed that it was reasonable to
hang mike pence let's go to yesterday's
testimony from cassidy hutchinson it
wasn't until
mark hung up the phone
handed it back to me i went back to my
desk
a couple minutes later
[Music]
him and pat came back possibly eric
hirschman too i'm pretty sure eric
hershey was there
but i'm i'm confident it was pat that
was there
um
i remember pat saying something to the
effect of
mark we need to do something more
they're literally calling
for the vice president to be effing hung
right
and mark had responded something to the
effect of
you heard him pat he thinks mike
deserves it he doesn't think they're
doing anything wrong
to which pat said something
this is acting crazy
we need to be doing something more
briefly stepped into
mark's office and when mark had said
something but marcus said something to
the effect of he doesn't think they're
doing anything wrong
knowing what i had heard
briefly in the dining room
coupled with pat discussing the hang
mike pence chance
in the lobby of our office and then
mark's response
there
to be the riders in the capital that
were
chanting
for the vice president to be hung
donald trump
didn't do anything about the hang mike
pence stuff
because he agreed with it and for
everybody disputing the testimony listen
if mark meadows instead of defying the
committee showed up took an oath
and answered questions we could clear it
up we could say hey you know what now
it's not just cassidy hutchinson under
oath now we've got mark meadows we could
get trump there under oath and have him
answer questions did you think it was
reasonable for mike pence to be hung or
hanged
um
but they don't want to show up they're
refusing to show up
so to the extent that people in the
media dispute these claims show up and
answer questions under oath let me know
your thoughts find me on twitter at
deepakman more on these explosive
hearings after this short break okay so
as yesterday's explosive testimony from
cassidy hutchinson was taking place on
washington d.c on capitol hill remember
under oath in front of the january 6
committee donald trump had a complete
and total childish meltdown on truth
social which only further sort of
suggests that the allegations about his
completely losing his temper and
throwing ketchup at the wall are
accurate
she was under oath trump was on truth
social truth essential yes exactly
take a look at this extraordinarily
childish meltdown from donald trump on
his platform as the testimony was going
on quote i hardly know who this person
cassidy hutchinson is other than i heard
very negative things about her a total
phony and leaker and when she requested
to go with certain others of the team to
florida
after my having served a full term in
office i personally turned her request
down why did she want to go with us if
she felt we were so terrible i
understand she was very upset and angry
that i didn't want her to go or to be a
member of the team she is bad news well
first of all if she's leaking she's
leaking accurate information you don't
leak you don't fabricate leaks it's
either a leak or a lie
secondly she is under huge legal
pressure it's not that she all of a
sudden disagrees with magga in fact this
is why i don't see cassidy hutchinson as
a hero she's acting out of
self-preservation she's not like some of
these other big names she is under
serious legal pressure here and so she
showed up and she told the truth as she
recalls it trump continuing never
complained about the crowd this is the
size of the crowd
cassidy hutchinson testified trump
wasn't happy with the size of the crowd
on january 6th trump wrote never
complained about this about the crowd it
was massive i didn't want or request
that we make room for people with guns
to watch my speech who would ever want
that not me
besides there were no guns found or
brought into the capitol building so
where were all of these guns but sadly a
gun was used on ashley babbitt with no
price to pay against the person who used
it
trump going on her fake story that i
tried to grab the steering wheel of the
white house limousine in order to steer
it to the capitol building is sick and
fraudulent
very much like the unselect committee
itself wouldn't even have been possible
to do such a ridiculous thing her story
of me through throwing food is also
false and why would she have to clean it
up i hardly knew who she was well when
you're trump lots of people you hardly
know are cleaning up after you sir
then trump can trump losing it over this
testimony she changed lawyers a couple
of days ago and with it her story
totally changed shocker
going on cheney conveniently left out
the snippet in my speech to go
peacefully and patriotically isn't she
disgraceful
trump going on there is no
cross-examination of this so-called
witness this is a kangaroo court well
remember republicans opted out of
participating other than adam kinzinger
and liz cheney her body language is that
of a total bull artist fantasyland trump
continuing will anybody ever be allowed
to say the election was rigged and
stolen will the unselects ever discuss
that our country is going to hell
because of a fraudulent election how
about analyzing the election results
trump continuing i never said mike pence
deserves it to be hung
another made-up statement by a
third-rate social climber trump
continuing a total phony
trump continuing reacting to a note
placed up on the screen
that was written by cassidy hutchinson
bad handwriting that of a wacko
trump continuing why didn't they use the
ten thousand troops i offered up on
january 3rd there would have been no
january 6th
actually there's been no evidence found
that trump had 10 000 troops ready to go
no evidence whatsoever
trump continuing the woman who was a big
trump fan long after january 6th if her
fake stories were true why would she
want to be
was let go and not wanted in florida so
she made up phony and completely
outrageous stories the crazy of which
had the craziest of which has already
been proven to be a complete lie that's
not true nothing's been proven to be a
lie
the secret service said according to the
media it wasn't true wow she has now
lost all credibility just like the
partisan witch hunt perpetuated by the
unselect committee of political hacks
maga
will put them under oath sir
put them under oath
trump then this morning
waking up with more of it
saying the new york times and washington
post failed to even mention that today's
unselect witness lost all credibility
when she got caught in a ridiculous lie
our country has lost all confidence in
the media and our elections sad
um
nothing has been proven false
donald trump completely and totally
losing it in a meltdown of historic
proportions if anything
trump melting down this badly for nearly
24 hours suggests the claims made in the
committee hearing by cassidy hutchinson
are at least quite plausibly true and
should be investigated and if there are
people who want to swear an oath and
come in and say i have a different view
then they should be invited to do it but
donald trump losing it on truth said
truth sensual truth social while cassidy
hutchinson is under oath to me i know
where i'm going to lean in believing i
trust the person who's under oath unless
we get some contradictory testimony
under oath so that's trump's reaction
let's now go to fox news's reaction this
is this is absolutely the best
yesterday
after cassidy hutchinson testified that
donald trump knew and wanted armed
people at his rally on january 6th that
donald trump assaulted a secret service
agent tried to commandeer his vehicle to
go to the capitol threw food at the wall
leaving a stain of ketchup having to be
cleaned up by a number of different
people after all these things happened
and the testimony was extraordinary
fox news was completely in shambles
first of all there's a moment where it's
just a silence they don't nobody knows
what to say nobody has any idea what to
say it's the most delightful
awkward silence
i've ever seen on fox news
we always point out that there's not a
push back and it would have been great
to hear jim jordan or some congressman
say some other angle to this but the
testimony in and of itself
is really really powerful
sandra
uh
you take this one sandra i don't know
just the most in the smirk on bret
bayer's face about like where do we go
from here really says it all indeed yes
i am here now brett um to your point i
just wonder for the for the country
watching this in this moment uh how much
this changed is what people believed or
did not believe right aside from it
being compelling i mean does it even
really matter at this point in time now
brett bayer then making a very good
point here he makes a good point and
it's a point i've made on this program
as well
cassidy hutchinson
is there in front of the bright lights
under oath
while trump is posting to his social
media platform
exactly
that from hearing it firsthand she says
that both of those men requested pardons
from the president i think what you
pointed to sandra was
the most compelling when she quotes mark
meadows saying
pat you heard the president he doesn't
care
he thinks mike deserves it he doesn't
think they're doing anything wrong as
far as they're literally literally
calling for the vice president to be
hung and then pat ciplioni says this is
effing crazy according to hutchinson
this testimony was very compelling from
beginning to end she obviously had
access to all of the players we are now
hearing from the former president on
various posts where he questions her
accuracy he goes after her directly says
he doesn't know who she is and said he
didn't lunge at the secret service agent
and the beast uh that didn't happen he
says he didn't throw his lunch against
the wall that didn't happen and that
she's lying
cassie hutchinson is under oath on
capitol hill
the president is on truth social
making his statements what is so
compelling i think
hard to argue i mean that's absolutely
true
and fox news just completely unclear on
how to cover this in the immediate
aftermath now later in the show we'll
look at what the prime time lineup did
with the testimony they were ready with
a smear campaign against cassidy
hutchinson they were ready to go but in
the immediate aftermath in the immediate
aftermath they didn't know how how do we
what do we do here and brett bayer
admitting this is some of the most
jaw-dropping testimony ever to take
place in the world of american politics
i've covered politics for a long time i
don't think there's been testimony like
this that is kind of jaw-dropping in a
way on the inside workings of a white
house crisis after
you know at this moment in january 6
that we've seen in since watergate right
and he's absolutely correct so by the
end of this news hour
they were starting to put together their
reaction plan and martha mccallum shows
up towards the end of the show
and sort of just starts to downplay the
significance of the testimony this was
the first step in kind of minimizing it
later in the evening fox news went full
out smear campaign on cassidy hutchinson
we'll get to that but here's martha
mccallum trying to run a little bit of
interference i would say john you know
i'd agree with um what you all have just
been talking about but i would say that
we had sort of the basic parameters of
what happened with regard to this we had
heard before that the president wanted
to go to the capitol and understand the
strategy here is
all along when we were hearing these
things they were denying that they were
true
now that the testimony has gotten so
specific and explosive from people so
close to trump now they go these are
was
i think that she comes across very
credible she has a good
memory for all of these different
conversations that were being had and
clearly the description of what happened
in the beast which is the president's
vehicle of course um of him you know
wanting to lunge toward the steering
wheel according to this account from
bobby who was the uh security secret
service person who was in the vehicle
who she says was very shaken up
afterwards
the question is um you know all of this
is
obviously riveting it's it's very
dramatic it was clearly um a very uh
difficult day for for her and for those
who were involved right everybody who
witnessed it i would add but the
question is in terms of of the
department of justice does it move the
ball at all
on any legal action that they could
pursue or
is it sort of an overall
filling in the gaps filling in the story
that has an impact on whether or not the
former president decides to run again
and whether or not any of these details
uh impact people's feelings about that
all around right even if it's all true
even though we downplayed it and denied
it all along and even if donald trump
was a completely unhinged authoritarian
madman hell-bent on keeping a presidency
that he didn't actually win and
indifferent to the potential hanging of
his vice president even if all of that
is true which we ran interference for
for the last year and a half does it
really matter at this point guys
uh an incredible incredible way to
downplay it and just remember
they had five hours to get organized
before prime time hit later on last
night
and after the break we will look at what
became a concerted and calculated smear
campaign against cassidy hutchinson
that's after the break if you're just
listening today and you want to check
out video of these clips that i've been
playing for you make sure that you
follow us on instagram you can find us
on instagram at davidpakmanshow
so as we already looked at in the
immediate aftermath of the testimony
this week from cassidy hutchinson before
the january 6 committee like in the hour
right after it fox news was completely
in shambles awkward silences brett baer
having no choice but to concede this is
some of the most jaw-dropping testimony
since watergate they didn't know how do
we downplay this how do we manage this
by the time the night time came during
the so-called opinion programming they
had a strategy and the strategy is smear
campaign against cassidy hutchinson
cassidy hutchinson who has really
nothing to gain from doing this other
than than
certainly receiving death threats which
i'm sure she started to receive by now
and hoping to avoid legal jeopardy which
is why i imagine someone of her position
would say yeah i'll show up and tell the
truth as i recall it the smear campaign
starts immediately first and foremost
they start accusing hutchinson of lying
just making it up for personal gain
how would that benefit her hmm okay
let's listen
i served with both bobby and tony they
are career civil service agents they're
former military they embody what career
government officials should be i would
take their word over any word of this
junior staffer who is completely i
believe lying to the january 6 committee
for her own self game bobby and tony so
first of all bobby and tony are not
under oath cassidy hutchinson is under
oath if we put them under oath and they
have a conflicting account
now we'll have something to evaluate for
the time being we have cassidy
hutchinson under oath
needing security now receiving threats
now getting doxed etc under oath and we
have trump posting on truth social and
we have media reports of two secret
service agents allegedly claiming that
if they testified under oath they would
have something different to say but they
want to say she's just making it all up
acted appropriately every single time i
travel with the president over 40
separate trips with those two
individuals i would love to hear them
contradict this lie with the truth but
i'm you know i'm a little different on
this one bobby and tony need to continue
to serve america we don't need to put
them on full blast oh okay so don't
they're busy doing work so even though
they would say something different under
oath we shouldn't actually bring them in
to testify so
the weakest possible attempt at smearing
her then we go to laura ingram laura
ingram has um
stephen miller on and miller goes she
was such a low-level aide but that
doesn't really contradict the subject
matter or the substance of what she says
she could be a low-level aid or not and
still have seen the the things she says
she saw and reach that way to get i
couldn't remember but it seemed the
whole no the whole story seemed
ridiculous but you knew you knew cassidy
hutchison what kind of a you know i've
i've met her a few times but i didn't
really have much contact look at that
she's she's she's an extremely junior
low-level aide i don't think i ever had
a conversation with her that i can at
least recall of any of any substance or
death but but to molly's point this is a
and remember
the fact that stephen miller didn't have
deep conversations with cassidy
hutchinson doesn't mean she's not
telling the truth test for your sanity
if you heard this story and you thought
man i believe every word of this i'm
going to go online and say something
about it energetically
something is wrong with you
something is wrong with you right if you
believe she might be telling the truth
you're the crazy person instead you
should believe stephen miller and laura
ingram ingram who by the way was quite
literally texting mark meadows about the
riots saying one thing and then went on
tv that night and said a completely
different thing running interference
saying it could have been the feds it
could have been antifa could it just
certainly wasn't trumpist or anything
like that she wants us to believe her
view about cassidy hutchinson when she
was implicated in trying to manage the
media coverage of those very same riots
and then ingram continues saying that
the entire testimony seemed like an
audition for the view do you notice she
kept saying
something something to that effect
she kept couching everything she said a
lot of it was hearsay
obviously not admissible in any kind of
real a court um but she kept saying
something to that effect whether it was
about trump's reaction to pence and the
hanging chant or what but i i found it
all it was like she was auditioning for
a seat of the view or now the fact that
she would say something to the effective
to me
doesn't really raise any red flags i
mean it seems natural if you're under
oath and you're not quoting something
verbatim that you would use that phrase
just think about an instance in your
mind if i think back this is just
something so banal right
let's think back to when i had a chipped
tooth repaired a year and a half ago at
my dentist okay i remember it vividly
it's not every day that i chip a tooth
and it's not every day that i get the
tooth repaired so i i generally remember
the the experience
if you said to me what exactly did your
dentist say
about uh what probably caused it
i wouldn't be able to quote my dentist
so if i were under oath i would go
listen my dentist said something to the
effect of
my bite and potentially grinding my
teeth at night led to the chip
it's accurate that was the
that that was the gist of what was said
it's completely representative of my
dentist's view but i don't remember the
words that were used it was a year and a
half ago so i would naturally say
something like well
the dentist made me understand that this
was the cause the dentist said something
to the effect of the fact that cassidy
hutchinson is using that term does not
to me raise any red flags now she may
just not be telling the truth but right
now we don't have any contradictory
claims under oath put someone under oath
and let's get some contradictory claims
um okay then uh then hannity what was
the next one here oh no uh ingram also
spoke to other people about cassidy
hutchinson
now the first attempted distraction or
shiny object
a former aide to mark meadows cassidy
hutchinson was slotted into what was
billed as a special super-duper special
session of the january 6 committee today
and i spoke with some former white house
staffers three or four of them in the
afternoon and they knew her well
and not one person
had anything good to say about her
performance today well why does it
matter why extremely biased people with
a vested interest in minimizing the
insanity of what happened think about
her performance why does that matter the
question is
did what she say
line up
with other testimony the answer is yes
did what she say get contradicted by
anyone else testifying under oath the
answer is no
and is she in any way
likely to benefit from this or is she
actually exposing herself both to legal
jeopardy and to death threats and to
needing security into being doxxed and
the answer is yes of course it does um
sean hannity jumping in and
participating on this as well he jumped
on the word hearsay hearsay has become a
big focal point of yesterday's testimony
today we heard more rumors a ton of
hearsay and wow a lot of impeached
testimony that we'll get to in a second
and this is why it's never hearsay is
never admissible in a real court of law
including this wild claim from a former
low-level white house staffer watch this
yeah so then he goes on to play the
testimony so the entire hearsay thing
all right
there are so so two things on that first
of all
the fact that cassidy hutchinson is
recalling what others said
does not really change our understanding
of it
in a congressional hearing it is true
that there are restrictions on what
hearsay is admissible in courts of law
we're not even talking about crimes here
yet so why they continue to talk about
hearsay well we know why because other
people here and they go it was hearsay
so wait but does does hearsay mean it
was false does hearsay mean that she's
making up no hearsay relates to courts
of law this is not a court of law but i
want to go beyond that there are 30
exceptions to hearsay not being
admissible in courts of law
oftentimes hearsay is admissible in a
court of law there's the present sense
impression exception this is a hearsay
statement which could be allowed if it
describes or explains something that
happened
based on something said by someone right
after it happened so
when she says hey this is what mark
meadows said right as they were chanting
hang mike pence i'm not saying it would
be allowed in a court of law but there
is a present sense impression exception
to hearsay restrictions in courts of law
which sometimes can be argued for
there's what's called the excited
utterance exception if you were
somewhere
and someone made an excited utterance it
was it happened close to whatever it was
they were reacting to
it was uh sort of like a visceral
reaction
it was um uh it it almost even startled
they just came out of the person making
the claim
that can be admissible because it was an
excited utterance and it may not even be
something the person who made the
utterance
would remember imagine that there's you
know imagine an explosion happens right
in front of you that's such an unusual
thing i might go oh
oh look at this i knew i knew this was
happening this was my cousin joe i knew
he was going to do i might not even
remember that but a court might say to
someone who heard me make that excited
utterance we're going to we're going to
allow that even though it's hearsay
under the excited utterance exception
the point here is
this attack on everything is hearsay as
if it's some open and shut thing well
it's hearsay it wouldn't be allowed in a
court and therefore it can't even be
believed in this setting it's bs and
it's a scripted and coordinated attack
last thing
mark levin on fox news
just completely losing it and demanding
that news networks fire their legal
analysts for not properly attacking the
entire january sixth committee
proceedings
you also do not participate in a
transition period
and order the department of defense to
work with the biden people easy buddy
they have no evidence for any this
committee's come up with nothing despite
the fact it's all one way and i want to
encourage
networks
all over the country who i'm sure will
listen to me
fire your legal analysts fire them
there's too damn many former federal
prosecutors this isn't about a federal
prosecution these legal guys they keep
coming on they know nothing about the
constitution a president a candidate has
the right to lobby
a lobby the state legislature if he or
she believes that the elector should be
for them just because he's yelling
doesn't make it true mark levin should
try decaf and he is just furious furious
that not every legal analyst is saying
it's all lies and it's all imprison the
people doing the investigation mark
levin isn't happy so that's the totality
of the smear campaign that fox and the
right wing put together in just a few
hours after cassidy hutchinson's
testimony okay last thing on yesterday's
testimony in the january 6 committee
hearings by cassidy hutchinson and this
has nothing to do with cassidy
hutchinson herself
liz cheney yesterday during the
committee hearings at the end revealed
that in mafia mob boss style
trump-associated individuals
have been contacting witnesses
and sort of suggesting to them er you
should remain loyal be careful what you
say
here is liz cheney
uh
revealing
what is quite clearly witness tampering
the intimidation of january 6 committee
witnesses
here's how one witness described phone
calls from people interested in that
witness's testimony
quote what they said to me is as long as
i continue to be a team player
they know i'm on the right team i'm
doing the right thing
i'm protecting who i need to protect
you know i'll continue to stay in good
graces in trump world
and they have reminded me a couple of
times
that trump does read transcripts and
just keep that in mind as i proceed
through my interviews with the committee
remember
trump reads transcripts
that's intimidation that's witness
tampering
here's another sample in a different
context this is a call received by one
of our witnesses
quote a person let me know you have your
deposition tomorrow
he wants me to let you know he's
thinking about you
he knows you're loyal
and you're going to do the right thing
when you go in for your deposition right
you're going to do the right thing i
think most americans know that
attempting to influence witnesses to
testify and truthfully
presents very serious concerns yes and
so this is the latest even within so
the the hearings are looking at what
took place and may find that crimes took
place
in
relation to the hearings it appears as
though more criminality is taking a
place our friend jamie raskin recently
appeared on our program congressman
jamie raskin was asked about this
and its potential criminality and here's
what he had to say
well the evidence of witness tampering
um
that the committee has released are the
two episodes that the vice chair
uh cited today anonymously for obvious
reasons
um it's a crime to tamper with witnesses
correct a form of obstructing justice
the committee won't tolerate it and um
we haven't had the chance to fully
uh investigate it or fully discuss it
but it's something on our agenda folks
there may be people charged with crimes
in relation to the committee like think
about the multi-layered insanity of that
you've got the subject matter being
investigated by the committee which
could lead to criminal charges
but you could have subsequently an
investigation
into trump world's
actions related to the investigative
committee and there may be crimes there
it's crimes all the way down seemingly
unbelievable what is going on we're
going to take a quick break we're going
to get to other stories including new
polling about the 2022 midterms and much
more stay with me
there's been a dramatic turn of events
in 2022 polling over the last couple of
months and i don't want to overstate
this but i also don't want to ignore the
story because when three four months ago
i was saying guys listen everyone must
vote and we have to do everything fight
for every seat all of these things but
it's not looking great for democrats in
2022 i think democrats will lose the
house i think democrats will lose the
senate some of you wrote to me and said
david why are you writing it off
you should just say we can win it was
like well i'm not writing it off i'm
just telling you what the polling is and
i'm being realistic the polling has
reversed reverse dramatically and
democrats are now ahead of republicans
in three recent polls looking at a
generic 2022 ballot a generic 2022
ballot means regardless of where you are
you plan to vote for the democrat or for
the republican this is not normal okay
and again
now there's the risk of of another
unintended consequence of mentioning
this which is if i say oh democrats are
doing great now then people will say
well i don't need to vote
um i don't quite frankly think this show
is big enough to have that much of an
effect one way or the other
but we all must vote but we should
understand the numbers three new polls
in a new marist poll in a congressional
ballot
democrats 48 republicans 41 that's a
plus seven for democrats that's a big
big deal
in a new political morning consult poll
democrats 45 republicans 42 that's plus
three for democrats and then in the new
yahoo news yougov poll
democrats 45 republicans 38 that's plus
seven for democrats
why are these numbers such a big deal
there's two reasons number one this is
not typically what you see
when one party has taken the white house
in the previous election in 2020
democrats took the white house from
republicans biden beat trump
you all know that
and typically almost always with like
three exceptions
when that happens you would expect
republicans to do really well in the
first midterms which would be four and a
half months from now in november so
number one the fact that the numbers
differ from that traditional historical
reality is a really big deal but the
second reason that it's a really big
deal is this is not the way the numbers
look just three months ago and i think
that we can all
sort of take a cynical approach here and
say
this is temporary it'll go back to
republicans crushing democrats by
november well it's not obvious to me but
one of the things we've been talking
about now for about two months is are
there unique circumstances in this
election that make it potentially okay
for democrats when republicans should be
winning and i say that the answer is yes
this is not a guarantee of anything i'm
still getting lots of people on twitter
saying david you loser
some of them say worse things than that
republicans are going to crush democrats
in november just wait and see well maybe
but there are some different
circumstances here first of all normally
when we say oh democrats can win by
running on abortion rights no
that
historically that's not a good issue for
democrats to run on it's not a winning
issue it's not a voting issue for
democrats it's the type of issue that
will motivate republicans to come out to
vote against a pro-choice candidate
typically that's the way it is
this time around it looks like it could
be different americans are more in favor
of abortion being legal in most cases
than at any time over the last 50 years
so public opinion is different now than
it has been on abortion and in addition
to that
republican
appointed republican nominee trump
nominated supreme court justices have
overturned roe v wade something which
two-thirds of americans are in
disagreement with
that is different and that means in this
election
that situation
could make it better for democrats
particularly if they say we're the ones
trying to keep these rights whether it's
credible or not that that's what
democrats are going to do
secondly
normally running on gun safety
regulation is a losing issue for
democrats we've talked about it before
we've talked about it with a number of
political strategists when democrats
make gun safety regulations a big part
of their campaign
it doesn't really motivate democrats to
come out and vote for them but it does
motivate republicans to come out and
vote against them however
the rash of school and other mass
shootings in the united states over the
last three months and just tragic
numbers hundreds of mass shootings in
the united states in 2022 so far
uh seem to have tired out and exhausted
many americans about the republican
party's unwillingness to consider
serious gun safety regulations and so
you have a situation where in this
particular midterm it might actually
work for democrats to run on gun safety
and on abortion rights so that's
different than normal the other element
that is different than normal in these
midterms is that we are coming up
against the tail end
of this six-year trumpian cycle and i'll
explain to you what i mean by that
normally you have a sort of
relatively similar electorate throughout
three elections so like if you look at i
don't know 2000 2002 and 2004 as an
example
the electorate george w bush won the
presidency in 2000 and then you had the
2002 midterms and bush won re-election
in 2004.
there was no major change to the
electorate in the year 2000 which then
had to sort of sort itself out in 2002
and in 2004 it was a very similar
electorate okay
that is not the case right now in 2016
you had all of these
formerly non-political non-voting people
who were enamored with trump a lot of
low information voters a lot of uh
extremists of different kinds people who
were clueless
these people were not participating in
politics before 2016.
they appeared in 2016
um and then in 2018
um
some of them voted in the midterms and
then in 2020
they were still around and trying to get
trump reelected and now trump's gone and
there's a real question as to do these
trumpets vote in midterms where now
trump isn't even a candidate and trump
is less visible and so many other things
are going on or do those people that
only entered the political space thanks
to trump's presence do they just kind of
go back to whatever they were doing
before i don't know what that is but it
didn't include voting we don't know the
answer to that but it's potentially
something that will really change
uh the makeup of the 2022 midterm
electorate so do i have a definitive
answer i don't but when we see
republicans were winning every generic
ballot three months ago
democrats are now winning every generic
ballot that is a major change and
potentially significant so i'm not ready
to count out democrats in 2022 but we
must vote
we must get involved in campaigns
phone banking all of it and we'll be
doing everything we can to cover these
uh to cover the important races and the
midterms at large
i want to mention this but not spend a
ton of time on it
again
people are talking about hillary 2024
i've actually seen some op-eds
saying hillary is exactly what the
democratic party needs in 2024.
this is very hard for me to uh believe
is a good idea for democrats in 2024. uh
one such article talking about this is
by cnn's editor-at-large chris saliza
it's an article called the whispers of
hillary clinton 2024 have started and uh
seliza writes in the immediate aftermath
of the supreme court decision to
overturn roe v wade conservative writer
john ellis went to the internet to make
a provocative case it's time for hillary
clinton to make another political
comeback he wrote quote now is her
moment the supreme court's decision to
overturn roe v wade creates the opening
for hillary clinton to get out of
stealth mode and start down the path
towards declaring her candidacy for the
2024 democratic nomination
ellis argument
is one joe biden will be 82 and is just
going to be too old to run again
and number two the democratic bench is
not terribly strong
he's not the only person eyeing a
clinton re-emergence
going on to write that juan williams the
democratic pundit recently made the case
that clinton should become a major
figure on the campaign trail this year
to reset herself as a potential
candidate for 2024.
um
i have two thoughts on this because i
i've been talking about there needs to
we need someone else we need there needs
to be someone else here and continuing
to recycle the same candidates doesn't
seem like a great idea hillary clinton
is no spring chicken herself okay in
2024
she'll be 76 at the time of the 2024
election so the idea that biden's too
old at 82
so what democrats need is 76 year old
hillary clinton i don't know that that's
like a super strong argument to me but
there's this intangible feeling that
even if you can at some kind of micro
level make this case
that the democratic party is just ready
for something different now i've said
some of the people i'm interested in are
jamie raskin
i know anti-semitism could be maybe a a
problem for him but i think jamie raskin
would be a fascinating candidate i would
love to vote for jamie raskin i think
john ossoff the senator from georgia
super interesting although maybe he's
not yet experienced enough maybe too
young
um i've listed other people who i think
are interesting none of them have the
name recognition of hillary clinton and
i can see that right away
but it seems like exactly the type of
mistake that democrats love to make to
say
now let's go with hillary once again i
just am not seeing it and it sounds like
a disastrous idea
but i want to hear from you let me know
what you think about this idea of
hillary 2024
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
i've talked about people canceling
memberships here's someone who's so
furious
about our recent guest hosts that he's
signing up for memberships merely to
cancel them listen to this
hello this is alan from new jersey i'm
calling to speak to pat because pat just
claims that luke beatley did a good job
substitute hosting the show yeah luke
bealey did not do a good job he did a
terrible job and i need to cancel my
membership and then cancel it a second
time that's how disappointed i am at
luke beasley is i can't cancel once i
have to cancel my membership then sign
up again and then cancel a second time
right to show how disappointed i am at
luke beasley he's horrible
he is pat
or
baron cousins or no one wow those are
the only two options pat barron cousins
or
no ones wow very very strong now
obviously he's kidding about signing up
just to cancel memberships
extremely strong feelings about our
guest hosts every guest host got rave
reviews and terrible reviews so we're
we're not picking on luke beasley here
at all uh there were people who wrote to
me and said luke was fantastic but i
can't stand farren's facial hair and i
didn't like pat's delivery there were
people who wrote in and said pat's great
he knows the flow of the show
everybody else is bad there were others
who wrote in and said the only guy ready
for prime time is farren pat and luke
don't know what they're doing listen
hopefully there was a little bit of
something for everybody that's the hope
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today stacks of bodies found dead in a
trailer a horrifying story we will we
will talk about it
elizabeth warren says democrats are two
votes away from codifying roe v wade but
is it too late and a study finds that
cannabis users are 25 more likely to
need emergency care or hospitalization
but is it because of the cannabis i know
i mentioned these were yesterday's
stories yesterday's bonus show was
canceled oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad
yeah because of yesterday's emergency
house uh committee hearing the bonus
show was cancelled so we will do those
stories today sign up for the bonus show
at
joinedpakman.com you can use the coupon
code indict
that's ind ict indict you all know what
it means everybody knows what that means
right now
sign up at joinpacman.com i'll see you
on the bonus show or otherwise back here
tomorrow